[Music]
do you remember what a parabola is
previously we saw that a parabola is a
collection of points which are at an
equal distance from a fixed point and a
fixed line let's take this as our fixed
point and this as a fixed line then the
corresponding parabola will look like
this the fixed line is called the
directrix of the parabola and the fixed
points is called its focus we also saw
that a parabola is symmetric about the
line that passes through the focus and
is perpendicular to the directrix it's
called the axis of the parabola and the
point where the parabola intersects with
this axis is called its vertex take a
moment to look at this parabola in this
video let's find the equation of a
parabola for this first of all we will
have to draw the x axis and the y axis
for simplicity let's take the x axis
along the axis of symmetry of the
parabola and the origin Oh at its vertex
then we will get the Y axis to be this
now before moving further let's name
this focus point as s and the directrix
as L also let's say the distance between
the vertex O and the focus F is a so a
is a positive constant now to find the
equation of this parabola let's take a
point B on the parabola and let its
coordinates be x and y now tell me what
do we know about this point P since the
point P lies on the parabola we know
that its distance from the focus F is
equal to its distance from the directrix
l so if we named this point as D then we
get this now to find the equation of a
parabola we will have to just figure out
what these distances are and for this we
can use the distance formula here it is
notice that to apply this distance
formula we need to know the coordinates
of points P F and DS we have taken the
coordinates of point P as x and y but
what about the coordinates of point F
and D can you find it let's first look
at Point F we know the distance between
origin o and point F is a so the
coordinates of point F will be a and 0
now let's look at Point D we know that
the vertex is equidistant from the focus
and the directrix since the distance
between the vertex and the focus is a so
this distance will also be a so the
equation of the directrix would be X
equal to negative a this tells us that
the x coordinate of point D would be
negative a also this point D is at the
same distance from x-axis as point B so
the y-coordinate of point D will be the
same as the y coordinate of the point P
so we get the coordinates of the point D
as negative a and Y now can you find the
distance between point B and F and point
P and D we now know the coordinates of
point P and point F so according to the
distance formula this distance would be
this and we also know the coordinates of
the point D so this distance would be
equal to this now if we simplify this
equation we will get the equation of
this parabola can you try to simplify it
for this we first square both the sides
of this equation we will get this now
take a notice of this term it isn't the
identity form of a minus B the whole
squared and this term is in the identity
form of a plus B the whole squared if we
expand the terms on the left hand side
we get this and on the right hand side
we get this simplifying this further we
get this
so we get that if a point P with the
coordinates x and y is on the parabola
then it will satisfy this equation can
we conclude from this that this is the
equation of the parabola
wait we also need to check whether the
reverse direction also follows that is
any point satisfying this equation will
be always on the parabola can you try to
verify this in the next lesson we will
verify this we will see that this
equation is the equation of this type of
a parabola what do we mean when we say
type notice here that the axis of the
parabola is along the x axis and its
vertex is at its origin and it's
oriented such that it opens towards the
right so for such a parabola this will
be the equation here a is a positive
constant which is the distance between
the focus and the vertex in the next
lesson we will also see what will be the
equation of a parabola with an
orientation different from this
[Music]